45 seconds of crazy long logos reading
also opening your Asian centric romantic
comedy with a fearful quote of war from
a French military leader seems a little
off
Jesus jumping subtitles with the size
and depth of these words not to mention
the thunder and downpour of rain in the
background I feel like I'm about to get
hit over the head with a blunt object by
a crazed beanie babies collector while
on my way to see the premiere of Ace
Ventura when nature calls
these make the Captain America's Civil
War subtitles seem subtle I'm sure you
and your lovely family can find other
accommodation may I suggest you explore
Chinatown and we're off to the racist is
I am selling the hotel to my dear
friends the young family of Singapore
classless classist caricature
condescends cartoonishly consequently
creating characters completely
comforting come up in Silesia you just
folded kings and nines in a two-handed
five card game I mean I get that we're
supposed to be learning something about
our protagonist here and it will mirror
nicely with the mahjong match later in
the movie but no one who knows the
slightest thing about poker is folding
that hand especially when you have only
a few chips left also you'd better the
hell believe I'm sitting the playing of
five-card draw
[Applause]
you didn't he fold it he still has chips
in front of it why are you stopping now
also how long have they been playing
this heads-up match based on the massive
amount of chips you are unnecessarily
playing with I'm guessing you started
with more players how long is this class
that you can do a full poker tournament
- luckily create a single teaching
moment instead of just pulling from
thousands of hours of existing televised
poker moments that make this point even
better I know for a fact that Curtis
does this mean you were playing for real
money the hell is this overproduced
object listen if he doesn't know how to
poker or professor actually thinking of
further east like Queens like Singapore
for Spring Break
Singapore Spring Break sounds like an
80s movie or Rob Lowe and Johnny Depp
both fall for league on and I'm sure
there's cross-dressing at some point
except how did she know it was Nick
before she walked in front of him to
snap the picture she was looking at the
back of his head the whole time in the
restaurant also I'm sorry but if he can
be this easily spotted and social media
bombed and there is no way this is the
first time in a year this does happen
and retold wouldn't know how famous he
is
[Music]
there is no way you heard him love
whisper that all the way across the
noisy restaurant
sorry Radio One Asia if that even is
your real name Nick takes many goes it's
hard to keep track
son slut-shaming Ephesians chapter 6
verse 4 but a second ago you were in
Colossians 3 chatting about setting your
minds on things about when those very
distracting and earthly text messages
started pouring it and now you're
jumping back to Ephesians to chat about
bringing a kids the right way when
you're having a conversation with one
how amazing that your Bible study has
random disconnected verses that applied
directly to the movies intentions we
were literally just talking about that
how could you know I mean gosh how did
you miss the whole two-minute montage
we're about a hundred people or so
Sherlock your girlfriend with fancy
graphics and cool swing music with a
passion and fervor that indicated it was
absolutely the most important thing
going on in the universe it was very
convincing this okay fine for whatever
reason slick Nick here hasn't told her
his family is loaded but if he knew they
were going to get the royal treatment
on the airline wouldn't he have at least
prepared her for this ahead of time well
this is my cousin Alistair based in
Taiwan works in movies oh yeah it's the
get to know the periphery characters
through an extended narration montage
part of the festivities my favorite
having you wear one of my pieces he's a
better publicity then I can buy movie
hints at an oceans 9 expanded universe
awkwafina's presents later all but
confirms I get there in a private suite
but this is first class not a private
plane this would be the akia version of
the baby crying the whole plane ride
more like singer rich numeron also this
helpful matt tells us that they are
going to Singapore it says it twice and
there's even a Singapore Strait to
further hammer that home and they've
been discussing Singapore this whole
time so it's only natural the movie
tells us we're in Singapore once again
in big bold letters I would remove 500
sins if instead of Singapore it said
Australia so that fancy curbside service
doesn't extend to the landing why are
these two carrying their own bags now 20
seconds of Singapore sightseeing porn
you knew what to do picky
somehow this hide the expensive shopping
routine happened so often that there is
protocol to be followed and yet not
organized enough to have a central
private location for these items to be
stored as opposed to being stuffed in
random drawers or covers you can use new
girlfriend Oh be there you like her why
cause she's a commoner like me oh goody
we have a parallel story so we can
understand that less fortunate people
can learn to be with rich people nothing
like a movie teaching the important
lessons
that means when it comes to these two
I'm just gonna go ahead and do what the
scriptwriters should have done in the
first place
skip vomiting merlion how is this but
Nick she's wearing glasses she's clearly
not hot and sexy anymore
nice to meet you too choo CooCoo
could you you poopoo I mean is she
feeding that infant an entire fried
chicken nugget I get that it's a joke
but it's like a joke from a cartoon or a
parody not a heartfelt romantic comedy
this whole crazy niche Asian family is a
tones throw in the wrong direction she's
American huh really skinny you want to
look like that
eat your Nuggets haha because kim
jiyeong is insulting Constance Wu
calling her ugly even though she's not
and comedy you keep on just rich okay
they're crazy with two thirds of roll
credits roll crits but the young family
their old money which they had money
when they left China so why did we need
the opening in the hotel getting this
film off on the absolute wrong foot when
Aquafina does a great job explaining
everything we need to know here without
the cliched racist Londoners in the
background tonight you need to not look
like Sebastian of the world Maureen
Jesus Christ this movie is bad mom zing
the beautiful Constance Wu more than bad
moms did de mila kunis also I have to go
to a dinner but I have nothing to wear
even though what I have on is perfectly
fine it makes me look hot cliche you
just copy and paste jungle and just kind
of threw it in there this argument seems
forced since there is obviously a gate
right in front of you and cards that you
would have clearly seen before they
snuck up on you for no apparent
non-comedic reason okay
don't stab the car it feels like a
Melissa McCarthy level of ad-libs was
allowed on set and that's not always a
good thing
oh my god it's a few hundred mil really
the wealth fantasy both in this is for
real yo this movie looks at affluence
like my 13 year old niece looks at
Taylor Swift it is the ultimate in human
achievement and we should all aspire to
such things it would be one thing if
this movie even wants not at at issues
of greed corruption or waste but nothing
wants to take a Scrooge McDuck dive into
its pile of gold enjoy your swim here's
15 cents bachelor well technically is an
Asian bachelor grief so what we supposed
to be funny right
unnecessary sound effect alert we know
what selfies look like movie you don't
have to hit us over the head with a
camera shutter sound every time someone
takes one almost don't even make that
noise unless you tell them to and even
then from that distance in that room you
would most certainly not hear it anyway
you prepped ready to face the moon
rachel is a New Yorker she lectures
Millennials for a living young might be
the nicest guy on the planet but he's an
asshole conceals as well from Rachel for
one full year never really tells her but
reveals it by boarding on a luxury plane
and doesn't make one attempt to prepare
her for his mother kind of relationship
is this what have their conversations
been like up until now why does Rachel
still trust this guy also is millennial
just a synonym for college age now
because the actual generation was born
from 1980 through 1995 or so meaning
most actual Millennials are likely out
of college now in fact based on the 1995
flashback at the beginning of the movie
where Nick appeared to be around 7 or so
he himself is a millennial and likely
Rachel too
so technically she teaches Gen Z for a
living right this is auntie onyx and on
sophistic hi it's so nice to meet you
every single person in this meeting the
locals montage will stand on the same
mark with the same background almost as
if they were placed there by a DP to
emphasize the repetitive nature of the
event instead of how introductions might
actually occur at a party your parents
like to entertain oh I'm sorry your
mother's single how would they know that
if you just don't ellen:oh her about her
dad dying a few minutes ago I saw
declaring why didn't you favorites man
can't wait to find out what happens with
Michael's startup tech company subplot
and I can't wait I mean don't give it an
to understand why a 2-hour movie that
should be 90 minutes tops chose to keep
the storyline it why would they want to
buy a rare Cambodian guys because they
couldn't find a rimshot so you might be
excited that the
skill that I bring home as a Chinese
professor chinese-american the movie
deservedly gets credit for its diverse
and expansive superstar Asian cast and
the way it captures Asian culture but
one of the most impressive things to me
is the subtle way it navigates the
nuance prejudice within the Chinese
culture itself the cultural education
and impact alone is well worth of cinema
someone forgot to wear a bra um so rumor
is she was in a porno two girls I've
heard Robert Downey jr. plays the cup of
noodles
not sure why I need to know this is
international waters or why these
subtitles are getting so ridiculous I
keep feeling like a new movie is
starting every time one of them pops up
but maybe this international water spill
was actually good is it directed by
Renny Harlin organize a party I see Nick
is using the cover your own Mike but
speak directly into someone else's mic
form of subterfuge very smart I
genuinely don't understand what kind of
comedy this film wants to be that felt
like something out of a Naked Gun film
also jinyang from Silicon Valley was in
charge of this bachelor party building
it up as something so insane he had to
host it in international waters what's
being done here is no different than
running out of club for a nice party
might be fun but it's needless bolt so
the guys are off drinking beers and
shooting rockets with bikini models and
the girls are capping off a cat a
free-for-all shopping spree by going to
a spa good to see gender stereotypes
remain in the same worldwide holy on a
shoelace where's that chopper barked is
that safe that cannot be safe Nick told
you that we went together right and we
have one goddamn romantic comedy that
doesn't have the old girlfriends during
a cliche this movie might have been a
game changer for an ethnically evolved
mainstream offering but it threw every
fucking rock at the rom-com cliche tree
to see what would stick Congrats on the
clever pun but do you have the hook and
fish emoji and your recently used or
something maybe I just suck at emoji but
it would take me at least a full minute
of very confused thumbs to find those
things
I don't usually focus on continuity
errors from one shot to another but the
way Rachel's arms go from cross to
uncrossed and then crossed again and
this edit here is almost criminal and
must be mentioned you just can't get
stuff this wrong and hope people don't
notice and I love Who I am around you
this line underscores a problem with
this movie we haven't seen Nick and
Rachel's relationship until now what
does he see in her and vice-versa
how did these two personalities mix the
movie spent three minutes showing Nick's
mom being turned away from a swanky
hotel only to have her husband buy it
which is fun but has nothing to do with
the core conflict of the movie
in bed tock time and you eat the baby
wait a pixar short wasn't a metaphor is
this just a thing microwaving macaroni
and cheese for their own children
no wonder they put their parents in the
orphans home when they grew up the
studies of the correlation between
processed cheese intake and not wanting
to care for your elders is long and dark
it's a beautiful ring auntie Eleanor
Nick's father had had made when he
proposed to me when shadowing Chinese
son think their moms are Chanel number 5
in fairness that's actually listed as a
skill on Michelle EOS IMDB super
sophisticated smart professor a frickin
game theory yeah maybe she can team up
with Robert Langdon in his symbology
courses and give us a double whammy of
course as no one gives two it's about
match the original tagline for this
movie and yet another makeover montage
are these just a requirement for females
and movies I mean even Wonder Woman add
one for pete's sake isn't it a bit
sexist I'm just saying I've never really
seen a guy do one because apparently men
just roll out of bed looking awesome
but women well you'd better spend a full
day with a full team of people or else
you won't look acceptable that noise so
this is the wedding day Rachel's still
somewhere getting an outfit picked up
for I'm pretty sure being late to the
wedding is not a way to get on crouching
Tigers good side have to fly into
sunshine on Monday and to try and talk
him down his cousin's birthday he's
doing good I don't even have so I can
throw another crop over on it again next
time around
thank you it's the double spanks I can't
breathe
spanks I hired a private investigator
and in just three days he was able to
figure out Rachel's mom's dirtiest
secret about cheating on her dad with
someone else and that someone else is
the father
don'tdon't dumb also this Maury Povich
moment comes during the celebration of
her son's best friend's wedding like
could you not spring this after
everything subtle you know like tomorrow
tomorrow never dies
Edie how are you even standing there
just a short while nothing like a good
laugh between mother and daughter about
a creepy stalker taking pictures of them
my mom taught me how to play he told me
my John would teach me important life
skills this mahjong scene is pure
brilliance you don't even have to
understand the game to get the symbolism
metaphor and beauty of this I have all
the cards but I'm letting you win MoMA
and Howard me or is the I have none of
the cards but I'm going to win moment
from the beginning but the more you look
into the actual game the deeper the
symbolism grows I don't have the space
here to go in
but I do have the space to take off a
few sins for one of the smartest and
most poignant scenes of 2018 so all that
stuff she just told Nick's mom realizing
she's not good enough for her son that's
still the case right surely she didn't
change her mind because she said some
pretty things and threw a single game of
Mahjong why yes this movie is trying to
make me happy that this rich Asian woman
gets to freely embrace her 1.2 million
dollar earrings a true love story for
the ages
I believe this character's name in the
script is constant whoo boyfriend waits
until his girlfriend gets on a plane to
make a final plea cliche
I just need 30 seconds for this woman
this is what I say to my wife every
night and then 15 seconds later she's
not happy with me yeah yeah that's his
mom's ring
so she gives her blessing but couldn't
Nick leave with that fact it's not a
twist if we see it coming so trying to
make this scene seem like a surprise is
kind of pointless we interrupt this
grand finale of feelings to point out
what may be the biggest slice of what
the pie in this entire movie is that t8
Curtis the teacher's assistant chump she
literally schooled in poker at the
beginning of the movie how the hell is
he here it just did the catcher before
the plane leaves proposal less than 24
hours ago and even if he did have time
to get there
which he most certainly did not why in
the hell would he he's her freakin
teacher's assistant how does he rank I'm
sure we'd all like to be weeping tears
of joy for our extremely wealthy Asian
brethren right now but t even Curtis
nice
Astrid finds happiness during the
mid-credits scene with discount Joseph
gordon-levitt
the most boring person ever poor what
about your cousin Eddie you know never
talked about him she's born without a
tongue Clark but don't you worry about
her she whistles like a bird needs like
horse either be the tractor thing how
are you 40 oh can you believe it good
and those beautiful you showing me your
nose like that he is more men than
you'll ever be
if we talk about truth bombs I'll take
shelter because I'm about to make the
Queen and if you dream don't sleep don't
sleep cuz she might disappear you could
be so nice
you
[Music]